oui bien ne pas voir le tekken 6 6
milles samedi puis de retour de mes
vacances j'ai pu décrocher pendant un
bon mois pour pouvoir me reposer une
ressource et profiter de la nature pour
enfin revenir vers vous avec bien sûr un
point de vue sur des actualités sur des
moments qui se sont passés pendant le
creux vide pendant ces périodes de
tension sociale est quand même de
beaucoup de mouvement social
cependant s'il ya une chose que
j'aimerais vraiment évoqué par lee qui
est passé à travers mots mon mur de
médias sociaux pendant le mois ce sont
les 30 ans de la crise d'octobre où
comme je préfère des fois le nommer la
résistance monrocq de 1990 pourquoi
revenir après je les laisse les
célébrations tous les le rappel de ce
moment historique c'est que ce moment et
puis quand même été fondamental à ma
présence dans les médias sociaux dans
les médias sur la scène justement de la
mobilisation autochtones à travers a
énormément mois - 90 j'avais 12 ans et
je vois la mobilisation droite au début
d'un très mauvais oeil puisque je me
disais non équipés quoi vous nous aviez
encore plus qui nous détestent déjà faut
pas qu'il fasse de bruit mais
tranquillement à mesure que justement
les événements avancé eh bien j'ai pu
voir des femmes extraordinaires comme
est longue et dure à prendre le devant
de la scène défendent les droits des
communautés autochtones de pouvoir
exister sur leur propre territoire de ne
pas être effacé de l'histoire
donc cette mobilisation la réveiller en
moins de très grande fierté d'être une
femme
ll nous même si c'était une mobilisation
pour moi cependant trois pas plus tard
est-ce qu'on peut encore célébrer un
événement qui a servi un peu de réveil
matin à la société québécoise qui à
l'époque et je me rappelle il ya encore
des attaques tonnes ici où je pensais
que c'était toute ma pensé que c'était
tout dans des réserves tranquillement au
cours des trente dernières années
on a pu voir un changement au sein de la
société une plus grande ouverture par
rapport à l'histoire commune au québec
on est fort aussi l'accueil qui a été
fait pour québec pourrait donc moment et
certains deviennent fille qui ne peut
plus juste à être cachés ou ignorés
cependant une des crises réalité trente
ans plus tard c'est que dans la
communauté des cas les stars et là où à
tout commençait justement la
mobilisation en europe
les peines les pins qui était en danger
le sont encore on voit encore
aujourd'hui une avancée de projets
immobiliers sur le territoire qui était
justement disputé à l'époque donc trente
ans plus tard malgré tout ce que cela a
provoqué malgré tout les avancées que
justement la société à faire ensemble
comment ça c'est que la nation qui a
débuté justement cet éveil
si beaucoup de jeunes autochtones et qui
aurait veillé justement la société
québécoise est encore aux prises avec
des problématiques sur ces territoires
non c'est dès cet hiver un moment de
l'histoire qui est arrivé aussi
ce sont chez les white sourit-elle quand
les chefs traditionnels se sont opposés
justement passage des pipelines et que
souvent nous faisait ouais mais les
chefs ont dit oui on n'est plus des
ententes avec les chefs et que c'est là
que au canada même une découverte de
deux systèmes très différents
le système traditionnel et le système
des conseils de bande qui parfois
peuvent être entre mais les liaisons
avec les autres puisque avant l'arrivée
des colons européens
chaque nation chaque communauté avait un
système politique où un système de
gouvernance qui lui était propre
donc chez les huit souhaitait non ne
plus entendre parler justement des chefs
traditionnels de la passation
traditionnelle dans la chefferie versus
celle des chefs de bande est bien là
même en jeu existe ici au québec et
c'est à travers la maison longue que les
morts se faisait entendre
bien sûr dans les années 20 on a vu que
les politiques soient la politique pour
restaurer les réserves instauré les
conseils de bande ont été imposées sur
les mois et même qu'on a vu la
destruction active du système politique
traditionnelle parce que
en plus d'être en dehors du système qui
était pensé pour les programmations
pensée pour les indiens et ce christ à
dire le conseil de bande
eh bien on parlait d'une gouvernance
féminine est d'ailleurs en 1990 qui at
on vu prendre la parole au devant des
caméras des femmes plus que le système
était mètre linéaire alors trente ans
plus tard on revend corps ses fans on va
encore la maison allons devoir encore
une fois avec un gouvernement différent
mais des enjeux similaires a mené les
problématiques des territoires mode qui
sont encore occupés et qui n'ont pas été
rendus justement à la maison au système
traditionnel qui via son et on va le
comprendre ne fait pas confiance du tout
au gouvernement canadien parce qu'en
1990 ayez toutes les commissions toutes
les rencontres qui ont été faites avec
les chefs franck non repasser à
l'oublier maintenant ya eu aucune
transformation au niveau politique et au
niveau territorial pour les morts avec
un récit paraît donc ses traits à dire
que 30 corps on voit les mêmes
problématiques
on voit les mêmes acteurs sociaux se
présenter au devant et de voir encore
une fois faire entendre la cause les
mauvaises langues hébreu qui doit encore
se faire entendre sur ces enjeux mais
bien sûr on voit aussi l'ignorance de
l'ensemble des enjeux par beaucoup
d'acteurs politiques qui travaille avec
les communautés autochtones et qui ont
encore une difficulté à faire la
distinction entre les chefs de bandes et
les chefs traditionnels comme sur la
maison donc j'espère sincèrement que on
ne parlera pas un autre 30 ans pour
faire entendre la voix des morts
j'espère que justement ça fait
comprendre pourquoi
quant aux veaux dans les courses prend
quand on est enfermé dans le système des
cours suprêmes pour faire entendre
chacune des causes de chacune des
communautés on est capturé par un
système pendant que justement
l'exploitation de territoire se fait
encore et au bout du compte quand ils
finissent par reconnaître parce qu'ils
peuvent pas faire autrement
reconnaître le droit autochtone bien
tout ce qui est assez des compensations
mais le territoire a été détruit
donc j'espère que vous comprendrez que
ce sont des enjeux qui sont difficiles
ce sont des enjeux locaux pour le québec
donc il faut ouvrir l'oreille il faut
écouter ce que la communauté d'ecône et
stocker 10 et il faut aussi entendre
quand il essaie même de tendre la main
donc il vient une pétition présentement
en ligne justement pour faire entendre
leur voix auprès d'une question qui est
vieille de plus de trente ans les mêmes
au delà de sa date depuis justement la
création des réserves comme camille sac
et cannois alors je vous invite à vous
informer vous avez été écouté le
merveilleux documentaire 270 ans de
résistance de alanis obomsawin pour en
comprendre plus les enjeux et je vous
souhaite une belle semaine n'hésitez pas
à partager ses vidéos et hésitez pas
surtout à renvoyer des questions si vous
en avez fait une belle semaine